[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que ça vous fait voir question
à monsieur vraiment là il m'a pris là il
m'a alors il m'a fait un mal de chien
non mais je sais je fusse t fait d'assez
souffle après la prochaine coupure
j'aime beaucoup ce balayage je tiens à
dire aussi qu'il ya un balayage qui est
très belle qualité et on voit ce que tu
sais pourquoi ça adoucit devrait
s'adoucir quelque chose note de l'école
ouais j'suis en adoucissant la main
dessus sur les normes sur les
conseillers ou de gauche parle pas de
notre ami là où c'est désastreux mais
[Rires]
question j'ai entendu dire que vous
trouviez matthieu delormeau très bons
comédiens et que vous voudriez tourner
avec lui peut-être l'an prochain film
génissiat oui bah mathieu vous aimeriez
tournai christian kalimba ce serait mon
rêve
alors je suis disponible au delà de la
vanne je suis disponible
g j'ai bien compris mais je voulais
simplement poser une question que j'aime
beaucoup aussi
the voice c'est normal connaît des
effluves de chaleur là sur le dans le
sol plateau la queen's là si tu veux
c'est comme si on était en tournant mais
là il déniche une soufflerie de chaleur
dans celle ci le désert d'un coup vous
avez d'astérix le tournage comme j'ai
dans le désir thing et il ya les jeunes
session saône à partir de 20h30
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas comment vous dire non mais
manquait le circuit quelque chose de lui
donner ça parce que c'est il a des
passagers by un truc alémany tient bon
sur le papier mais non est génial
[Applaudissements]